today on the matt well show democrats
attempt to legalize abortion through
every stage of pregnancy up until birth
nationwide meanwhile people are getting
sent to prison for killing bald eagles
and harassing turtle eggs our law and
democrat policies literally place
animals and bugs above human beings
we'll discuss plus handmaid's tale
cosplayers show up at amy coney
barrett's house and proceed to embarrass
themselves because what else could they
possibly do and a republican senate
candidate is caught on tape in shocking
video claiming that the gender pay gap
is a myth huge scandal he's also
completely right we'll talk about that
for our daily cancellation we will
attempt to make sense of the latest
gender innovation which is called cake
gender all of that and more today on the
mat wall street
[Music]
did you know that if you're currently on
a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you're helping these
left-leaning companies donate to
pro-choice pro-abortion causes and
candidates common question i get from
listeners is what can i do to help turn
the ties in the culture war here's a
great first step defund the abortions
don't let them take your money and use
it to further policies that you don't
believe in switch now to charity mobile
today and they'll send five percent of
your monthly plan price to a pro-life
charity of your choice charity mobile
offers the latest 5g phones with no
device or service contracts plus great
nationwide coverage that sounds like a
hassle to make the switch i assure you
it is not charity mobile makes switching
from your current carrier painless and
easy they're live customer service
exceptional they'll guide you through
the process you can keep your number you
also can keep your phone in most cases
if you want or you can take advantage of
my special offer and get a free cell
phone with free activation all you got
to do is call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem the free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com mention
offer codewalsh and join the the fight
today uh for the lives of children by
switching to charity mobile
last year two guys named bruce wayne
bivens and carl lawrence cobb were
sentenced to seven months in federal
prison for the crime of harming
or potentially harming turtle embryos
florida fish and wildlife investigators
who were surveilling the area at the
time
caught bivins and cobb red-handed
digging sea turtle eggs out of the sand
in the middle of the night and then the
two dastardly crooks stashed their
ill-begotten gains in a bag and they
jump into a truck and they drove away
but law enforcement were hot on their
heels like an action movie and they made
the stop and they they confiscated the
sea turtle eggs
and then they arrested both men and the
sea turtle community was made a little
safer for seven months at least as these
dangerous predators were taken off the
street and put behind bars now bivins
and cobb are far from the first or only
people to be prosecuted under the
endangered species act
and sentenced to prison and hit with
hefty fines as well
only a few years before that three men
were sentenced to prison
for drunkenly
jumping into a swimming hole in nevada
or what they thought was a swimming hole
anyway and then they inadvertently
smushed the eggs and larvae of um
the endangered pupfish which is native
to the region and you gotta be very
careful if you're in nevada swimming
because there are pupfish around and if
you hurt one then you could go to prison
one of the culprits spent a year
in the federal penitentiary penhead
jerry for that crime
he was lucky to get off so easy given
that he was guilty of mass murder i mean
he killed
dozens of these pupfish eggs
but you don't have to kill an endangered
species to provoke the wrath of the
legal system the endangered species act
prohibits even the harassment of
protected species which is why a
construction worker back in 2001 was
sentenced to jail time plus 200 hours of
community service and a fine for
relocating 64 california red-legged
frogs and also 500 tadpoles from his
construction site to what he thought was
a safer location he was actually trying
to help the the frogs out because he was
like building something and the frogs
were there and he said well let me like
relocate them he didn't realize that
this constitutes frog harassment which
is a federal crime and he paid dearly
for his ignorance now if they had been
another kind of frog you would have been
fine but these are the red-legged frogs
and everybody knows that you cannot
touch a red-legged frog without going to
jail
this is a legal pitfall that people in
the construction business are
particularly susceptible to entire
construction projects are frequently
shut down and sometimes the people
involved find or senses to jail time if
they inadvertently disturb or irritate a
protected species in 2016 a 48 million
dollar road construction project was put
on hold
because it threatened the habitat of a
three-inch long fish called an okaloosa
darter
now it would obviously be a great
tragedy if the okaloosa darter was
inconvenienced which means that human
beings must be inconvenienced instead
right like we can choose between the
okaloosa darter
having to you know accommodate us or we
can accommodate them and of course we
choose them every time
as it happens a few years later the u.s
fish and wildlife service removed the
fish from the endangered species list
anyway
so now you're you're entitled to harass
the little bastards all you want but at
the time they were on the list and that
means you can't do it
now i thought about these kinds of cases
and again there are many hundreds more
that i could mention when i heard
yesterday about the democrats failed
attempt to pass the so-called women's
health protection act which would have
legalized abortion through every stage
of pregnancy for any reason up until
birth all across the country every
democrat except for one joe manchin
voted for the bill
now it failed anyway which led to lots
of hand-wringing from the baby killer
squad uh for example here's camila
harris's reaction listen to this
i just presided over the women's health
protective act vote and sadly the senate
failed to stand in defense of a woman's
right to make decisions about her own
body and let's be clear the majority of
the american people
believe in defending a woman's right her
choice
to decide what happens to her own body
and this vote
clearly suggests that the senate
is not where the majority of americans
are on this issue
it also makes clear
that a priority for all who care about
this issue
a priority should be to elect
pro-choice leaders at the local the
state and the federal level
because what we are seeing around this
country
are extremist republican leaders who are
seeking to criminalize and punish
women from making decisions about their
own body
god forbid criminalizing the destruction
of human life
i mean human life is not a sea turtle
let's get a grip here
now in fact the majority of the american
people do not agree with the democrats
despite what kamelahara says um they
don't agree with the democrats that it
should be legal to jam a vacuum tube
into the base of a baby's skull in the
eighth month of pregnancy and suck his
brains out of his head
the majority of americans do not agree
with
democrats that it should be legal to rip
a fully developed infant apart lim from
limb that's what democrats believe and
want and have already put in these laws
into place in many of our most populated
states and even where they have not
fully gotten their way it is still the
case that abortion for now anyway and
for the past 40 plus years
is still legal in every state which
means that
humans in the womb
have fewer rights
have less legal worth fewer protections
than sea turtles or california
red-legged frogs or the uh blessed
okalusa darter
there are indeed hundreds of species on
the protected list which means hundreds
of species have greater legal
protections in the united states of
america than human babies and this
includes insects plants
there are several different types of
beetles which if you were to step on
them intentionally or unintentionally
you could do a stint in federal prison
for it there are trees whose branches
you cannot break without risking your
freedom there are snakes and snails and
clams which all enjoy a legal status
above
that of a human child
and to make matters all the more
grotesque and insane
the fetal
and embryonic stages of all of these
animals are also protected the law draws
no distinction between an embryonic sea
turtle
and an adult sea turtle
when it comes to sea turtles there is
never a time when they're considered
just a useless clump of cells
only human beings are considered totally
worthless in their earliest stages of
development think about that for a
second
in this country only human beings
are legally worthless in their earliest
stages of development
a beetle egg
or a bee larvae
enjoys a higher status than a human
being at any point
in his gestation
this does not um just apply to
endangered species either by the way
bald eagles are not endangered they've
been off the endangered list for 15
years and yet federal law prescribes two
years in prison for anyone who kills
harasses a noise insults or breathes too
close to a bald eagle or its offspring
a few months ago a man in louisiana this
was this year was sentenced to prison
after be being found in the possession
of a bald eagle feather
and they found him with a feather and
then they interrogated him okay they
brought this guy in and they
interrogated him for having a bald eagle
feather where'd you get the feather
where did you get it and he admitted
under interrogation that he had hunted
and killed the bird oh dear god
dear god not the bald eagle
u.s attorney brandon brown who was on
the case explained why they had to throw
the book at the eagle killer
he said um the american bald eagle is a
symbol of our american freedom
this defendant did not take this symbol
seriously nor the laws that prohibit
anyone from killing or possessing even a
feather of a bald eagle
it's a symbol of our freedom so we're
gonna send you to jail
we're gonna send you to jail for not
respecting freedom
you're gonna sit in this jail cell
and think about why freedom is important
now what does um
that's what a huge that's what a bald
eagle symbolizes okay
what does a human child symbolize
nothing apparently or he symbolizes if
anything a burden an inconvenience an
obstacle to be avoided or destroyed
according to federal law you cannot so
much as touch a bald eagle feather
because of the eagle's great symbolic
significance that is in the law that's
what the law is
but babies can be killed
harvested for their parts
the rest of them discarded as medical
waste
think again about this for a moment we
have not just given greater legal worth
to animals but greater symbolic worth
also
and that symbolic worth is so important
to us that it's codified into law there
is no reason really why the bald eagle
should be considered inherently special
i mean i like bald eagles as much as
anybody else i think they're very nice
and pretty but why is a bald eagle any
better than any other kind of bird
the difference is that we feel a
personal attachment to the bald eagle we
see the bald eagle as especially
beautiful and majestic and that's reason
enough to protect it under the law
apparently
and yet a human child
is there no personal attachment there no
beauty or mystery or majesty that we
recognize
not according to democrats
now pro-abortion people will usually
offer some sort of defense of this
insane dichotomy by insisting that well
human beings aren't endangered and thus
don't require the same protections i
mean i've heard this many times i
brought this this whole thing up on
twitter yesterday
and this is the response i got you know
dozens of times well uh you [ __ ] humans
aren't endangered
now this ignores the fact that as just
established not every specially
protected animal is endangered but
leaving that aside this kind of logic
would for one thing justify the
legalization of the murder of humans at
any phase of life
if humans are expendable because they
aren't endangered then why can't i walk
up to my neighbor and shoot him in the
head he's not part of a protected
endangered species
the answer of course is that my
neighbor's inherent value his legal and
moral worth is not contingent on the
laws of scarcity
he's not some kind of object an item on
a shelf a product whose value fluctuates
according to supply and demand
it would be a moral outrage and a legal
crime for me to murder my neighbor today
and it would be no less of an outrage if
i waited until there were eight billion
people on earth instead of seven
you know i i can't
even right now i can't murder my
neighbor and then say what's the big
deal there's seven billion other people
on earth
what do we need that guy for
i i can't argue that
and we can see the logic with with born
people we can see why it doesn't work
that way with born people uh we could
see it for now anyway
it's only with the unborn or become
somehow for some confusing
but the tragic reality is that in
treating the unborn
as expendable as literally less valuable
than insects and lizards
we have whether we mean to or not
devalued all human life if human life is
totally worthless at its earliest stages
then it has no inherent worth
because inherent means that it belongs
to a thing by its very nature
belongs to a thing in other words as
soon as that thing comes into existence
and if that's the case if it has no
value by its very nature no inherent
worth then we don't have inherent worth
either
our laws have put us lower on the totem
pole than bugs and beasts
and this is the consequence of living in
a culture dominated by run by defined by
an anti-human death cult
all human life is cheapened and degraded
as we bow to inferior species
and you know
while performing this act of humiliating
self-debasement placing ourselves on a
rung of the ladder somewhere below toads
and crayfish
yes there are federally protected
crayfish by the way
as we do this ironically we end up
devaluing even the animals we have
seemingly valued above ourselves the
entire ladder topples over
because if we can't identify any reason
why we as human beings have inherent
value then there's no discernible reason
why any form of life should have
inherent value
and if you don't believe me just ask a
pro-abortion person to explain
why trees and butterflies have value and
you'll see what i mean
they can't explain it or the best they
can do in explaining it is is to
describe their own subjective experience
of those other things
they say that the bald eagle's beautiful
the tree is beautiful that's your
subjective experience of the tree
so what you're saying is that the trees
value it really hinges on your own
experience of it
but a second if if the value of these
things it all comes back to the fact
that we personally find them beautiful
or whatever then but but we have no
value
then how can the value that we assign to
things mean anything
they can't explain this
the elevation of animal life over human
life ends up being something of an
illusion actually
legally it's very real i mean the law
literally on paper
puts animal life over human life puts a
tadpole over an unborn baby
but philosophically
we're all just tumbling into the
nihilistic abyss
where nothing means anything
nobody's worth anything
and nothing has any actual
value at all
but other than that things are going
great let's get now to our five
headlines
[Music]
all right a little bit more
on
on this this vote yesterday by the
democrats um as democrats are very very
upset that uh
that they were not able to get the this
this law through and on the books which
once again to uh to emphasize
re-emphasize this with what they were
trying to do is legalize abortion for
any reason
through every stage of pregnancy up
until the moment of birth the moment of
birth like the moment when
the baby is coming out of the womb
anyway
and
either the child's going to come out of
the birth canal dead or alive
but one way or another it's it's
happening
and what the democrats say is that um
you could kill it right right kill the
child right before it comes out
and of course obviously there is just
no difference scientifically morally
philosophically
at all
between killing a child five seconds
before he's born and killing him five
seconds after he's born or indeed five
years after he's born
um but as they're reacting to this i
want to play this clip from katie porter
she's a democrat representative and um
she's
she was on mscbc yesterday explaining
how you know we really need to get a law
like this passed uh and have the
abortions you know keep churning out the
abortions because one thing is that it
will help solve inflation listen
president biden has said that inflation
is the number one priority for the biden
white house to try to get under control
right now
uh as you're out there in california
talking to constituents uh during this
re-election year for congress uh
how does inflation compare to this newly
uh important in the sense of the supreme
court decision pending uh
abortion issue how do those two issues
compare
well i don't think they compare i think
they actually reinforce each other so
the fact that things like inflation can
happen and it can become more expensive
to feed your kids and to fuel your car
um is exactly why people need to be able
to be in charge of how many mouths
they're going to have to feed so i think
the fact that we're seeing this jump in
expenses
that we're seeing people having to pay
more in the grocery store pay more at
the pump pay more for housing is a
reason that people are saying i need to
be able to make my own decisions about
when and if to start a family so i don't
think we're going to see them i don't
think it's about comparing them or
contrasting them i think they reinforce
for people just how big of a
responsibility it is to take care of a
family
uh yes it's uh we gotta kill kill the
babies because otherwise it's just more
mouths to feed and so this is the same
argument we've heard over and over again
we heard it yesterday from janet yellen
the secretary of treasury and this is uh
the argument but once again relating it
back to the the opening there uh you'll
never hear an argument like this when it
comes to animals
similar to by the way like climate
change we need abortion because it'll
keep the
carbon emissions down because there's
fewer people
well i mean animals ex you know also uh
give off carbon emissions so
maybe we should start killing some of
them off for the sake of that and also
what about the expense
i mean the enormous expense
that that we've had to
undertake
to keep these animals around how much
money are we spending the u.s fish and
wildlife service all to enforce all
these laws
send them through the court system
we're talking over the years easily
billions easily billions of dollars
you know at what point is it too much at
what point is it too much to protect the
reticulated flatwoods salamander
which is i'm just looking at the list of
endangered species protected by the the
law and there are again i mean there are
hundreds you can go through
they got spiders on here
the spruce fir moss spider
um how that's well there's a bunch of
spiders on here also
so at what point
is it too much money
to spend on these animals well what
we'll hear from people like katie porter
is that
oh there's it can't possibly be too much
to protect the uh
the rednecked parrot
or is it
it's like what is this the ash-breasted
tit tyrant
that's the name of a bird
i mean i know it sounds like someone you
might meet at the women's march march
but uh the ash breasted tit tyrant is a
bird so what what
what katie porter would tell us is that
there's no amount of money i mean if we
we have to spend billions more trillions
to keep the ash breasted titan around
then it's worth it because that is life
damn it
but human life is an entirely different
deer who cares now now when it comes to
human life let's start looking at the
dollars and cents let's figure this out
you know
if um
there was a different situation now with
inflation and with the deficit and
everything maybe we could afford to have
more people but we really gotta you know
we gotta start rationing we gotta start
rationing human life according to what
we can afford to keep around
and it is only human life that we take
that approach with
not the ash breasted tit tyrant
i'm going to continue to try to find
ways to work
that into this show as we continue along
um speaking of ash breasted tit tyrants
their handmaid's tale protesters showed
up at the at amy coney barrett's house
yesterday so they've been hunting down
all the supreme court justices and they
finally made their way to amy coney
barrett
and uh fox news was there and they
interviewed one of the the protesters
and i thought um what they had to say
was
pretty unintentionally hilarious listen
to this
this catholic
catholic
is letting their
religious doctrine
interfere
with their ability to write sound
legally
it's also possible that the fact that
she is an adoptive mother
is influencing her inability to see what
it's like
to carry a pregnancy to term
well she's had five kids on herself by
herself
not everybody wants to have
five kids or four kids or one kid
uh
so her her first response you just see
how they they just go with the flow like
it doesn't matter they're never taken
they don't lose a step
right when they say something that's
completely wrong
and then you tell them oh but that's
you're completely wrong about that
they don't lose a step they just keep
charging forward oh well that line of
attack didn't work i'll just switch over
to this one which even though this one
is completely contradicts what i just
said so she begins by saying wow this
woman doesn't even know what it's like
to carry a child to term oh but actually
she's carried five children to term
well not everybody wants to have five
children
but she thinks because she has five
children then everybody should have it
you see it's two completely different
talking points
on one hand it's oh well she's only in
favor of abortion because she's never
had to go through this
and then we switched to oh well she's
gone through this a bunch of times it's
just she thinks everyone else should
this is once again the advantage um of
being
not just a soulless wench but
also being a moral relativist and those
two things come hand in hand almost all
the time but this is the advantage of
being a relativist is that the truth
doesn't matter at all you're not
troubled by it
and you're just simply going to say what
you think
you know what whatever is the most
useful in the moment whatever talking
point is the most useful you're going to
use that one
and if it turns out not to be true then
you'll switch to something else doesn't
matter
and uh
but you notice something too
they're showing up there in their
costumes and they're in everything at
amicone barrett's house
uh
there's there's only a handful of them
though
and that's kind of the dirty little
secret here that the democrats don't
want you to notice
is that they are not getting
the national backlash and outrage that
they expected or wanted
like they didn't want just five weirdos
and handmaid's tale costumes that they
got at the at the halloween store they
don't want just them showing up they
wanted they thought and wanted and hoped
for
a thousand people outside of amicone
barrett with actual pitchforks and
torches
and instead they get five weird
middle-aged cat ladies in red robes
walking around
and because they thought
that that's the kind they thought it
would be national
explosions of outrage
over the possibility and what it seems
like the near certainty at this point
that roe v wade is overturned
and they're not getting it actually
and now they're panicking even more
which is why
they have already basically changed the
subject
now they've got the women's march coming
up this weekend they've got another big
women's march and i'm still getting they
got a big crowd for that because they've
got you know they pretend this is all
grassroots it's all astro turfed and
everything they got a lot of money
behind it a lot of paid protesters and
everything and they're gonna you know
they're gonna put all their money into
getting a big i'm sure they'll get a
there'll be a big
scene in dc and in you know uh los
angeles and
austin and other liberal cities
but after that it's gonna kind of be the
end of the activism that's my prediction
because people just
are not nearly as upset about roe v wade
being overturned as the democrats
thought they would be and hope for all
right i want to go to this now um
the
pennsylvania republican senate primary
uh we know that
it's it's kind of come down there there
are you know there's three or four
people that are in the race still but
it's really kind of come down to kathy
barnett
versus dr oz and kathy barnett sort of
exploded onto the scene
last week when she took dr oz to task
for his for his support of abortion in
the past
and uh she had a very powerful you know
some very powerful words from her own
experience um and why she's she's
pro-life
and now the
the
so-called conservatives who have become
dr oz shills for some reason
have set out especially over the last
couple of days
it has been an onslaught to try to
destroy this woman kathy barnett and
they're putting they're taking out of
context
clipped things and they're making
montages and putting it online they're
digging through her tweets is what
conservatives are doing
digging through tweets from like nine
years ago
to try to find offensive things to take
this person down
and but what they're actually finding
is that um they're really working
against themselves because as they dig
through our tweets what they find is
that oh back in 2014 she was pro-life
she was socially conservative
as opposed to dr oz who
back 10 years ago as we played on the
show a few weeks ago
10 years ago he was pushing puberty
blockers for trans kids so-called
quote-unquote trans kids
now what do you understand about dr oz
when it comes to the gender
ideology issue in particular is
um he was
on the forefront
of pushing gender ideology on the kids i
mean this was a he did a segment his
first segment on it was 2010 2011.
so he didn't even he didn't jump on the
bandwagon
he was driving the bandwagon
to push puberty blockers
and gender confusion and gender
transition onto kids now that's all we
need to know about him actually that's
that's enough that should disqualify him
forever and more than that anybody in
the on the right who's shilling for him
is also as far as i'm concerned
disqualified forever from having any
kind of credibility
um someone who was
pushing gender transition onto kids no
period
like i don't care what else you've done
in your life
i don't care if outside of that you've
been a war hero i don't care if i i
don't care what else you've done
you do that you're disqualified
that's happened with dr oz though it's
just this is just one in a in a parade
of uh
of leftist radicalism that we've seen
from him he's pro-abortion while kathy
barnett even six seven eight years ago
was speaking out
to protect the unborn six seven eight
years ago dr oz was pro-abortion two
years ago he was pro-abortion
pro-gun control
you know he was talking about um
uh
systemic racism and then only this is
less than two years ago about a year and
a half ago
this was a segment on dr oz's show
about the jacob blake case let's watch
this here
shot seven times in the back
family of jacob blake speaks out he was
trying to kill myself
his devastating injuries hurts to
breathe rehearse his sleep do they think
he'll be able to walk again then behind
the horrifying death of daniel prune
and mental health crisis gone terribly
wrong i called for help and that was the
help they gave them they don't even
treat animals like that next to us
this was not 20 years ago this was in
2020
and he was pushing the jacob blake false
narrative
and i don't hear any excuses about oh we
didn't know at the time
um if
if you're an honest and rational person
you knew immediately that the narrative
over jacob blake was false i knew
immediately first time i saw the
video before we even knew all the other
details i mean i didn't know initially
that jacob blake for example you know
allegedly broke into this woman's house
and uh and raped her and then uh stole
her credit cards in her car and all that
and then he showed back up at her house
and she called the cops and that's what
precipitated all this like i didn't know
that backstory i wasn't surprised by it
when i did learn it but just watching
the video it was clear enough
that he was fighting with the cops he
was at least trying to steal a car he
was reaching into a car he had a knife i
mean you could see all that in the video
and this is why the police officer in
that case was not charged with any crime
because um
because
he didn't do anything wrong
jacob blake was a thousand percent in
the wrong so this was dr oz back in 2020
less than two years ago pushing uh you
know
the radical blm agenda and a false
anti-police narrative coming to the
defense of jacob blake who was an utter
total
woman abusing predator scumbag
and now there are
conservatives who want who want him to
be in the senate
as a
republican
like this guy he has
zero record
of anything remotely conservative
his entire record his entire public
career has been spent pushing leftism
in its most radical forms
and he doesn't even live in pennsylvania
he's a turkish citizen
so a turkish citizen and new jersey
resident
leftist is running for
the senate as a republican in
pennsylvania
and he's being uh he's being pushed and
promoted by
very prominent people on the right to
include president uh you know president
trump
all right
here's someone actually deserves is a
republican running for senate who
deserves some promotion blake masters is
running for senate in arizona he's a
republican which you already know that
based on the fact that msnbc is going
after him
and they in fact are trying to expose
him now so they've obtained video and
i'll play you this segment they they've
obtained secret video
that they found from a
public campaign event
i don't know why it's secret video um
where he says this listen
there's a new video that we just
obtained actually out of arizona another
senate race that we are going to be
looking at that is still crowded trump
has yet to endorse in this race but one
of the candidates who has already made a
trip to mar-a-lago is blake masters the
other peter thiel candidate along with
jd vance who has been heavily financed
by the billionaire i want to let you
listen here this is the first time we
are airing this anybody is hearing this
this was blake masters back in february
when he was asked the question about the
future of the equal rights amendment
take a listen
women are not paid less
in america than men
it's a left-wing narrative this gender
pay gap
when you control for the occupations
when you control for people taking time
out to you know birth children uh things
are actually pretty equal and men do the
most dangerous jobs men are the ones who
are the police officers uh not all of it
but you know 80 of it in this country
men are the ones who are doing risky you
know fishing crab fishing in alaska and
sometimes those jobs pay more
sometimes those jobs pay more and so i
think we got to push back on the fake
left-wing narrative that women don't
have any poor rise in this country i
want women to have import rights
but we don't need an equal rights
amendment that would actually just be a
trojan horse to give the government more
power to implement kamala harris's
national gender strategy right this is
what the left does when we have to
resist it
now chuck in this video here this is
what we're talking about when we're
talking about the new republican party
of today and there's much we could
tackle here
around what you just heard from blake
masters but one of them i think it's
important to pair is to know there is a
gender pay gap here in america
um
that and the reporter's name is von
hilliard which is just perfect somehow
uh perfect perfect name for him so
vaughn he's very impressed with himself
too when you cut out of that clip you
get back to him he's just kind of
standing there you see that i got the
goods on this guy
i'm a good reporter
meanwhile it's at a again a public
campaign event
he's on stage in front of a crowd like
he's not embarrassed about this getting
out there
in fact blake masters himself tweeted
this video out because he's proud of it
and he should be because what he's
saying is 100 correct and not only is
100 correct but it just shows you how in
touch with things msnbc is
it's 100 correct and it's something that
conservatives have been arguing in the
mainstream for years this is a totally
normal thing
that many of us have said many many
times
and they hear it over at msnbc and
they're they're shocked by who would
ever say this i don't know who would say
like
any conservative would say that
with the exception of maybe the
establishment of the republican party
like maybe they're not going to say it
because they're a bunch of milk toast
cowards but anybody outside of that will
and it is a thousand thousand percent
true uh the gender pay gap is a myth now
the way that they come up with the
whatever it is and it kind of changes
but now it's whatever 75 cents on the
dollar 77 cents whatever it is
um
the way they come up with that is number
one there's just
an element of straight-up fabrication
that goes into it
and then for the rest of it
they do it by taking all of the women
who are
working
you know who are in the professional
world in the working world
and taking all of the men
and just comparing them
but of course you can't do that
and this is how this is how we you know
this is how statistics
um this is how you end up with you know
damned lies and statistics you can lie
with statistics
because you can't you can't do that
that's not a relevant comparison
because when you do that then you're
taking like for example um an airline
pilot and most airline pilots are men so
when you're just comparing all men to
all women that means
that you are taking
an airline pilot
and comparing him against a hairdresser
you're taking
and comparing their salaries
can't do that
what you have to do
is take
first of all take it profession by
profession
and then find people of both sexes
with
um similar levels of experience
similar levels of skill
seniority
putting in the same amount of hours
etc etc etc
narrow it down narrow it down narrow it
down
and so that you have a valid comparison
and then compare them
so you need to show me that
a a man and a woman
in the same industry
doing the same job
with the same levels of of a
seniority
same numbers of years of experience
um
same skill level
same responsibilities
show me the disparity there
and when you when you narrow it down
that way the gender pay gap basically
disappears
and the thing is even if you did find
just a random anecdotal example of that
which i'm sure you could find of course
i could also find anecdotal examples of
of that situation where the men is paid
let men has paid less
but if you found me an anecdotal example
of of the reverse
that in and of itself still
does not prove the theory
that the woman is paid less
because she's a woman
the next thing i'm going to ask is um
well has the woman asked to be paid more
you know it could be that this is this
is one of the one of the secrets of uh
you know working a job if you didn't
know this
is if you want to be paid more if you
think you deserve more
the first thing you have to do probably
is go to your boss
and ask for more
it doesn't mean you're going to get it
but you might
see a lot of times bosses they're not
going to pay you more if you don't even
ask for it if you appear to be satisfied
with your current level of pay
and you're not scheduled for a raise or
whatever
they're not necessarily going to call
you in and say i'm going to give you
some more money
i mean the good bosses will but you know
there are plenty of bosses who won't
um
so that's why you gotta go in and ask
for more
and not just for a race too but during
the salary negotiation process
let's see one thing that men are more
likely to do is they're more likely to
assert their own you know interests
ask for more money
they're going to drive a harder bargain
during the negotiation process men are
more likely to do that so they're going
to get paid more
but even even with all that in mind
still when you when you narrow it down
and you come up with comparable
you know you have an actual comparable
situation
the gender pay gap goes away
now
why is it that women often end up in
industries that uh that generally pay
less
well because that's what they choose
like there are a lot more women who are
hairdressers a lot more men who are
airline pilots
it's just because women are more likely
to want to do that kind of job perfectly
fine
and also as blake masters points out um
there's there's a matter of priorities
a woman is more likely to prioritize
her family life home life having more
free time
which is also great
you know it's that's a that's actually a
good thing to prioritize men are more
likely to prioritize just going to work
and work in all the hours
and you can go too far on that end of
things
uh i know from experience but that's why
this is the the great thing between men
and women is that there's a little bit
of the balance there
all right
let's um
i guess we gotta get now to the comment
section
all right scott says i guess this is our
chance to ask why doesn't biden just
solve world hunger instead of sending
all that money to ukraine that's a good
point the 40 billion dollars that we
sent to ukraine
and we just heard because
elon musk is paying 44 billion
for twitter and we were told that with
that money you could have solved world
hunger so that's that's an excellent
point scott thank you for bringing that
up
uh
yeah if that if that amount of money
could solve world hunger why haven't we
done it
we chose to give that money to the
ukrainian government
we're going to line the pockets of
ukrainian bureaucrats and the defense
contractors
rather than solve world hunger because
it's apparently that easy to do
um
let's see
melanie says matt has not researched the
britney spears issue enough it could be
that she's a bit crazy but why is she
these are subjects that he needs to
research more well i don't need to
research it more because i i have
of all the things going on in my life
and issues that i care about
i'm just not going to spend a lot of
time researching britney spears
maybe in research it's like
sort of i guess i'm going to sit down at
night i'm going to have all books open
and you know i've got the pence with a
pencil in my ear i'm taking notes
researching the britney spears situation
i don't care that much i admit that
and so i also admit that my take on the
issue is really kind of a
gut level reaction but i think it turns
out to be correct
my gut level reaction from the very
beginning is that i don't know a lot
about the situation
but i do know that she's under a
conservatorship she's had public mental
breakdowns she lost custody of her kids
as a woman as a rich famous woman in
california i know all of that i don't
know much else but i know that
and so it stands to reason probably if
i'm a betting man i'm gonna bet
that she's crazy and a danger to herself
and others and that's why she's under
the conservatorship and should probably
still be under one
and i think her behavior after being
released and freed
has only further proved that point
and i also think
tragically unfortunately that um
the point is going to be proven finally
you know
five ten years down the line because i i
just don't see her living that long
um on the path that she's that she's on
as someone with a history of being
self-destructive
suddenly freed you know and sent out
into the wild open world because of a
because of a hashtag campaign basically
um i i don't see that ending well
sadly so
uh let's see what else we got
matt jimmy says matt did you see that
taylor lorenz sets her apartment to 87
degrees explains so much i did see that
so that was on on twitter apparently
taylor lorenz she's the washington post
reporter who docks the libs of tick-tock
remember
while crying about being traumatized
because people criticize her
so on twitter apparently and she has me
blocked but i saw the screenshots she
said that she she first said that she
drinks three gallons of water a day
which
just seems like way too much you're
gonna overwhelm your internal organs
with that much water but also uh and
then and she explained why she says that
she sets her that her apartment is 87
degrees that's what she sets her
apartment at
so she lives i mean that it does explain
a lot i guess
she's a lizard taylor lorenz is a lizard
she just hangs out under a heat lamp on
a rock
she's either a lizard or maybe a
different endangered species like for
example the ash breasted titan
mike debbin says
men don't wear sandals with or without
socks that's how the breakdown of our
culture got started normalize
normalizing men wearing sandals
so jesus
wasn't a man
the vikings weren't men
william wallace wasn't a man i mean i
would say on the contrary all of the
greatest men in history have worn
sandals
uh jessica says we officially need to
get matt to 1 million subscribers walsh
interpretive dance motions preferably
through the aisles of a theater maybe
the only thing that sustains us until
the november elections m says the spg
needs to choreograph an interpretive
dance for matt when he gets to one
million subs
justin says i pay for the daily wire but
jumped on youtube to subscribe to help
the cause and get a dance out of walsh
joshua says everyone hold matt to the
promise of an interpretive dance at 1
million subscribers jonathan says
looking forward to your interpretive
dance mat
this should be reserved for those who
subscribe to dw
now listen let's just hold on a second
i know people are very excited a lot of
comments about me doing interpretive
dance because i did technically promise
that but but but just let's just stop
and think about this for a minute
not
not every promise that a person makes
like there are things can happen that's
all i'm saying
i'm just filled with so much regret
right now i don't know why i said that
it was it was
talk about an unforced error
there was no reason why i had to promise
i don't even remember now why i said i
was a fit of insanity and i just
promised an interpretive dance
and now people are messaging me and
telling me that they're that they're
making youtube accounts
just so they can subscribe to see the
interpretive dance
you people are gonna regret it first of
all
do you understand what me dancing would
look like i don't even know what that
would look like i've never done it
but i guarantee it'd be deeply
disturbing it's the kind of thing you
will not be able to erase from your
minds
so that's just my warning
you have been warned
well it's the most infamous supreme
court case in memory and the deadliest
decision in history but even 50 years
after roe v wade few know the full
gruesome truth behind the landmark
decision decision that's enabled the
destruction of over 64 million babies
since 1971. well tomorrow may 13th the
daily wire will take a wrecking ball to
the four big lies the abortion industry
is built upon tune in to the world
premiere of our original documentary
choosing death the legacy of roe and
uncover the inside story of how roe v
wade came to pass and why it needs to
pass away you'll hear the facts and
stories the abortion regime has
suppressed for generations and get a
clear-eyed view
at the brutal reality they desperately
don't want you to see some of this
content is hard to take in but few
subjects if any are more important than
this check out the trailer
many times when we
did this
as we started
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus it was too late to stop
[Music]
i was handing hush money
to women who we had left pieces of their
baby
we had put these women's lives in
jeopardy we'd put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for 800
and for a poor woman 800 is a lot of
money
i mean there have been so many moments
in the last decade plus of going
undercover in abortion clinics myself
and seeing just heartbreaking things
women vomiting in the hallway of an
abortion clinic crying out in pain the
late term abortionists talking casually
about how they would literally leave a
born alive baby to die or if you deliver
the baby in the toilet then you pick it
up and stuff it in a plastic bag and
bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit
they are being drowned
their necks are being snapped
it's it's happening more often than
people want to think about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women and
you're just you're realizing it you're
watching in front of your own eyes play
out america's greatest horror story
which is
how we butcher children
in the name of choice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so please help us expose the truth tell
your friends to watch and if you're not
already become a daily wire member tune
in friday to our documentary on abortion
choosing death the legacy of roe go to
dailywire.com
choosing and join the fight today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know in recent times we've
encountered so many new fake made up
genders that you may think you can uh no
longer be surprised by the latest
innovations in the gender market and
perhaps this one will not surprise you
but it does point us towards some
insights that are worth reflecting on
libs of tick tock brings this to our
attention the uh the hottest thing going
on right now
fresh out of the oven it's called cake
gender
listen
okay i would describe zeno genders as a
gender that could not typically be
described with terms such as masculinity
femininity neutrality androgyny things
like that it's more of
not how you relate to a particular
gender
experience but more of how you relate to
things
for example cake gender um
i know
a few people who personally use this um
it's typically described as them feeling
light and fluffy or sweet and warm and
it's not something that you could
typically describe with the terms
masculine feminine androgynous etc
another example of cake gender would be
if someone feels like they have
different layers or flavors to their
particular gender
cake gender
now i have no idea why
first of all if you're going to choose a
pastry related gender you would identify
as cake which is by far the most
overrated and most frequently
disappointing dessert item
i could see maybe pi gender cookie
gender brownie gender
that last one may be problematic you
know from a racial perspective i don't
know
then again those other genders i just
made up probably already exists i mean
exist inside some troubled tick tocker's
head at least these are actually tells
us examples of xenogender
and i'm told by
non-binary.wiki that xenogender is a
quote non-binary gender identity that
cannot be contained by human
understandings of gender more concerned
with crafting other methods of gender
categorization and hierarchy such as
those relating to animals plants or
other creature slash things
yes someone who has zeno gender a term
invented by somebody on tumblr in 2014
by the way
is so complex and deep and poetic that
they can't be contained by human
understandings
they transcend thought and reality and
coherence
the xeno-gendered individual cannot even
relate to mere mortal human beings like
you you and i she is beyond them above
them like a a goddess floating in the
clouds
she cannot be compared to any gender
instead she can be compared to
cake
now if you're wondering
about the pronouns for someone who is
cake gender they are and i looked this
up
cake cakes and cake self
so
here's an example sentence
cake went by cake self to the bakery to
get a cake to celebrate cake's gender
transition to cake
after the doctor replaced cake's
genitals with cake so that now cake can
live his cake and eat cake while being
cake
hopefully that clarifies things for you
of course i'm being unfair i mean i'm
making cake gender people seem very
extremely insane when they're merely
just extremely insane after all the lady
on tick tock says that a cake gendered
individual does not necessarily identify
as a cake but rather identifies with
cake
she says that someone who's cake gender
and she knows a few people more than one
who identify this way
it's really someone who feels that
they're light and fluffy and warm and
sweet
now this is confusing to me because the
times when i feel fluffy
like i did last night after eating too
much indian food
those are precisely the times when i do
not feel light at all so i don't really
understand that be that as it may
this actually reveals something quite
clarifying and important about the
pronoun phenomenon i think
what it shows is that when these people
talk about gender and pronouns
what they're really talking about if
they're talking about anything at all
is personality
now i'm skeptical that anybody who
identifies as a baked good could really
be warm and inviting but if they are
that's their personality it's
personality not gender personality your
personality is not your gender it's just
your personality
you don't need a pronoun to describe
your personality that's not what
pronouns do
you don't need a gender to describe your
personality that's not what a gender is
these are all three separate categories
of things
now if i were to identify myself with a
food item that encapsulates my
personality
i suppose i'd have to identify as like
the shoe leather that you would be
forced to consume if you've been
stranded at sea for seven months and
your food stores have run out
but rather than claiming that i am shoe
leather gender it'd make more sense to
just say that i have a rigid tough
distasteful and unpleasant personality
and that would make a lot more sense and
also be true
now when you come to understand this
fact about about the gender and pronoun
mania gripping our culture it begins to
make a little more sense still not very
much sense but a little bit more
as we cover many times much of this is
born from sheer narcissism these are
people who spend far too much time
thinking about themselves analyzing
themselves inspecting themselves
categorizing themselves explaining
themselves to themselves
they've kind of rolled their eyes all
the way back into their heads and now
they spend their whole lives looking
back into the caverns of their mostly
empty minds
that's one important element of this but
the other is that
these people suffer from confusion i
mean all sorts of confusion obviously
but especially category confusion
they've conflated the personality
category with gender
and in so doing they've essentially
erased personality entirely
i mean now there is no personality
no variation within types that's why
these people they notice they never talk
about their personalities
they only talk about their genders
their gender type because there are only
types
they see gender as a filing cabinet with
a thousand drawers and each part of them
goes into a different drawer each part
is cataloged and labeled and categorized
and when they're done divvying
themselves up there's nothing left
there's no room for personality
ironically in their obsession with
identity they've left no space for an
actual identity
they've not only categorized themselves
to death but they also have turned each
part of themselves into a gimmick a
costume
everything authentic has been lost i
mean if you're a woman who also happens
to be sweet warm and inviting
that's a wonderful thing i mean you
should be that sort of person
we need people with that personality in
the world there are too few of them
right now
but the moment you turn that into its
own gender
you've just made your sweet authentic
personality into a weird
fetishistic charade
you've made a parody of yourself
and you've lost the thing that would
have made you distinct and interesting
and valuable to society
this is the consequence of the
genderification of everything
we lose
what was distinct and personal and good
and unique
and we end up with
cake gender
and that's why cake gender
along with cakes themselves actually
are today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show inflation
remains near record highs as joe biden
fails to change course democrats try and
fail to pass a law enshrining abortion
until birth and joe biden's sec is
reportedly targeting elon musk that's
today on the bench bureau show give it a
listen